[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on fait croire oui combien courbé sur le
maillon faible bloquer la barre haut or
on l'a envoyé en vacances on est
tranquille et benayoun benhaim malade
j'ai eu la tâche et leur nombre pourrait
de ce pays
[Musique]
et demain bano d'assez bons vins comme
prévu le filet la grille pain tout roule
voilà fait mes calculs sont bons tous
trois semaines et on reprend les rênes
de l'émission croisée 2-1 à temps qui
s'occupe de lemoine je m'en charge
mais ça va pas être une mince affaire la
téloche est un vrai panier de crabes
c'est qu'il est coriace levier
[Musique]
bon fils points alors j'ai une bonne
nouvelle c'est que jean luc lemoine a
décidé d'abandonner la présentation fait
en revanche j'en est mauvaise
luna est de retour le chien il a dû ce
bourg et vitamine c est le con ce qui ne
sait pas c'est que j'ai un plan de
secours
filoche
[Musique]
à suivre
on fait le point je crains de ne pas
avoir de bonnes nouvelles c'est pas
c'est pas la mort du petit cheval et
c'est pas bien de faire un scandale et
dans le temps d'en reprendre sur
internet en longs l'arthrite et
polémique n'existe pas il a préféré
aller dans 7 à vous plutôt que de casser
la gueule d'hanouna temps le parking des
je veux pas comment on va s'en sortir
avec ces conneries messieurs je crois
que ceci pourrait vous intéresser
quézako qui s'accouplent l'ignorent un
grand professionnel comme java rivera le
trac de venir au grand étonnement la
mort d'un jeune roi je tenais à
féliciter de ma part et de celle de
komball pour ce coup de pouce inespéré
venez l'extérieur on va passer à l'étape
supérieure maintenant il faut que tu
balances des saloperies sur lui à
l'antenne pour nuire à son image
populaire comme promis on t'envoie les
pâtes de fruits et puis voilà votre
continuation
si je l' ai vu qui n'a pas changé bon
allez je suis là oui nous restons tous
pas rater l'oeuf ou la poule ce soir à
20h50 sur des mythes quelqu'un me
regarde caméra y'a que moi qui peut les
faire rire
parce que nous ne sommes que deux en
france à maîtriser se retourner de tête
et guy lagache et moi à suivre
bon on fait le point le point il est pas
glorieux
s'il se rabiboche avec tous les
animateurs de la chaîne il en voudrait
pas gérard d'être partir grosse tête je
le reconnais plus attendre j'ai
peut-être une idée
bon je vais pas y aller par quatre
chemins
le deal est simple vous le verrez
l'antenne on reprend les rênes de
l'émission et en échange on vous donne
10 épisodes de mad river tombé du camion
et ça qu'ils accourent 10000 euros cash
malgache
alors il en dit quoi mais vous me prenez
pour qu'il vous ne faites pas moi
l'ex-régie il faut se rendre à
l'évidence on n'y arrivera jamais et ça
me rappelle ce que disait guy lux et
loges pour toujours avoir de couilles
avance le problème c'est qu'on en a cinq
de retard
monsieur jean ma possession quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser
merci jean louis
cyril hanouna est éteint et d'un plutôt
un camarade de la maison bien qu'ils
soient dans une chaîne concurrente ans
s'il est disponible je sais qu'il
trouvera un téléphone de valentin
d'accord vous aimeriez de recruter sur
le site les gens talentueux ont toujours
leur place sur un petit tu vois combal
les affaires reprennent ok la braise
c'est pas fini en même temps tu t'es
plutôt pas mal débrouillé à la
présentation de neuf c'est moi chef
l'idée est simple il faut qu à nouna se
dirigent de lui même vers la sortie
parce qu'il aura été poussée à bout par
un membre de sa propre équipe j'ai pensé
à vous je vous porte le décor il faut
lui bourrer le crâne avec des chiffres
part d'audience part de marché ménagères
pdj j'y comprends rien mais je vous fais
confiance là dessus et surtout être très
très très lourd au niveau des vannes
parce que c'est facile ouais pareil mais
je préfère un monsieur et madame asselin
ont un fils marc marquez un toit c'est
une bien lourde
je crois que vous êtes l'homme de la
situation à icônes and its bertrand
thank you d'avoir parlé du plagiat là le
rapport aux tuto de mokhtar la vidéo que
je t'ai envoyé à dos à la think you tu
me facilite la tâche
[Rires]